our mission is the extinction
of magic let's let's talk about the
arthurian legend in general
why do you think this is something that
we keep wanting to revisit
in different ways see it from different
characters perspectives
it's really interesting you asked that
because like i've always been a real fan
of history and a real fan
of um fantasy and you see so many
different perspectives and and retakes
of the arthurian legend um
you know particularly with king arthur
and merlin and the knights the round
table there's just a lot of that
folklore and mythology
um that's kind of i think ingrained in
some way in our in our literature
um but it's interesting because you know
we never
we never really see it from the female
characters within
this epic tale like you said yeah i mean
this is something that's been told over
and over again that's been
you know part of literature for hundreds
of years and so
i think it's kind of bizarre in a way
that this is the first time we're seeing
a kind of a um an origin story if you
will from one of its most prolific and
powerful characters the lady of the lake
yeah i mean she's like oh gee she kicks
everything off there
is no arthur without her like you know
nicki minaj she like burst him kind of
like that so why do you what do you
think is going to be interesting for
folks to kind of get to see this
character what are they not necessarily
going to
what are they what can they expect from
her so she's not someone that's talked
about
as much in the books i
i mean i don't know i think the maybe
i'm by it but the best
the best thing i think to think about or
expect going into this is expect
nothing just go in with with an open
kind of mind and be ready to
to see what you see i mean within this
series obviously we have these iconic
characters like merlin like arthur like
they're all there
but they're there in a way that you've
never seen them before
and i think especially with her and with
nimway this is
it's such a kind of unique tale and it's
it's
i think it's familiar but it's also a
very
clean new lens and so i just say go into
it open-minded with no expectations and
take
take something fresh from something
that's so old and familiar
well one thing they can't expect just
from the trailers is how much like
horse and sword fighting is like
throughout this and having seen it
there's even more than you think
so i'm just gonna ask which was harder
for you the horse or the sword fighting
because i know you had to spend a lot of
time with both
that's a really good question you know
i'm so i actually trained as a former
athlete i was a swimmer for nearly 10
years and i was really excited to be
able to use my body in a way that i
hadn't before with other roles
um i it's tough because i loved
the sword fighting and i think with the
sword fighting um
i it's something that i'd love to dive
deeper into if we continue this story
but
i worked with our amazing fight
choreographer mo to really
find a specific fight style for nimway
because the sword that you see and all
the weapons that you see
they are traditionally catered for men
and so you know
our fight styles that we see often in
film and tv they are
predominantly catered towards men so it
was really interesting being able to
take time to develop
that uh but i also love horses like i'm
such a sucker for animals and horses and
i really i really did enjoy that bit so
i might have to lean more towards the
horses but i i did love both
that's surprising for me because i
figured you would have said the sword
because you do some really cool sword
stuff
i mean it's the sword right it's
excalibur but
i will say you also kick some butt and
like if we're gonna say for netflix like
the two
like the king and queen of fantasy would
be nimwei and geralt of rivia
so i'm just curious who do you think
wins going toe-to-toe
that's a good i mean geralt's got what
like a couple of hundred years of
training
we see nimway and she's just taking the
sword so if if
if you give nimway like a couple of
years of training i i don't know i mean
it could go either way but
i think there's a lot that we haven't
seen from nimway yet so i'm kind of
behind her i'm also biased
really quick you guys were having to
film this over you know a long period of
time it's basically
ten mini independent films that you're
trying to like put together to make this
really epic story so i'm just curious
what was the best part and maybe the
worst part of having to do this like
really long and really i would say high
value production
um i mean i kind of feel like you just
said it i mean
the on one hand you know this probably
was the most it is actually
it was the most grueling shoot i've ever
done and i've done been lucky enough to
do film and tv and
tv is such a different beast um
but you know to do something this epic
which you often see in films
and then to shove that into ten months
into like you said kind of ten
one hour films um it's a lot of work and
it's really
it does take a toll on your body um and
even just to keep up with
the story not only you know keep on top
of the physical side of it and the horse
riding the training and making sure you
don't get injured
but also keeping tabs on the story
because nimway's entire journey is
locked in with this story so every time
there was a script change i would have
to go to tom
um i think that was a really incredible
learning experience but
also like it was so cool i don't know if
i can swear on this i was going to say
so
cool but like do it girl say it say it
just like that
and it was seriously to like walk onto
set
and to kind of literally walk in her
shoes every day and be around horses and
sword fighting i mean like
as a fan of this genre it's just so cool
to be able to do
so like it comes at a price but i mean
that gets weighed out like it was so
much fun i promised her
arthur i will keep that promise
what is harder when you're making a
comic book adaptation
and what really makes a good sort of
like graphic novel adaptation what are
the elements
i think everything depends on on on your
partners
you know and i've been very very lucky
in that respect
but i'd say what what makes let's see
what makes a good adaptation is where
your source material has to be the kind
of thing that can be adapted
it has to be it has to be something that
where the pictures are telling the story
you know something that that isn't
preaching along with its with its words
so much that you've got nothing to look
at
and be beyond that you need to have
capable
minds and hands to to
to make it all come real i can mention
everything from set design to
directing to to all the the big guns
like that
but let me bring it down to some smaller
things
i've had the opportunity to work with
with with excellent people in
costume and in in
weapons makers for instance and and
and and property and prop makers these
people work
very very swiftly and with great skill
some of them have to do
have to make things that look absolutely
perfect but may only hold together for
the moments you're shooting
because they because they have to do it
so quickly
but i would get ideas on the set of
curse for for
the costuming of nimway that would be
very complex
cross-stitching down the side of her
legs for instance
and the customer would come back with
with the leggings
within within no time at all and
when it came to swords i would ask for
swords and there'd be an array waiting
within the hour
and at one point tom and i actually came
up with a
with it with a horrible scene that i
couldn't resist doing because i've had
my
problems with with teeth in my life
i i said i really we've got to have a
medieval
dental surgery scene and you know
tom gave the nod and and and so we put
in the request for
to have someone come in with medieval
dental tools
that was right that was a that was a
rough meeting i'll tell you the
dental torture implements meeting and i
wasn't that was like
but you'd have fainted if you'd seen
these things absolutely
well that's good i mean the cornucopia
of talent you're dealing with it's
wonderful
yeah i mean and like you mentioned with
the swords if you're gonna do an
arthurian legend
you better have a sword you gotta have
excalibur
but it brings me to like the bigger
point which is that why and i'm gonna
start with you
tom why do you think people are still
drawn to the arthurian legend and want
to see it
with you know different adaptations and
different perspectives like why are we
continually wanting to revisit this from
a storytelling aspect
it it really is a foundation stone of so
many
stories that we love it's the it's you
know from star wars to lord of the rings
to i mean you can just everything seems
to owe a debt to
this imagery and these characters and
the
the unbelievable combination of romance
betrayal redemption um as frank has said
you know
characters who kind of are trying to
pull civilization out of a barbaric
world
so i think um it has had moments where
it's revived and disappeared and revived
again i mean i think it's
i think it's relevant to today you know
i think
um some of the you know we we
it was important to us to bring
something new to the table because it is
a story that's been told for
a thousand years so um
for me i think you know my
my daughter was 10 or 11 when we first
started talking about this story and
and for me it was important to see if
there was
you know a character in this mythology
that we could build out that she might
get attached to that
you know this idea that a woman held the
sort of power before king arthur
you know hopefully could empower her and
you know give her that sense of you know
that that kind of thing we felt because
that drawing the sword you know
taking control of your destiny at a
point where you might not feel ready but
um is is so universal and
and belongs to men and women and and i
think um
you know just briefly there was a moment
you know early on when my daughter
came to set and saw catherine you know
as nimway you know
and the full costume with the sort of
power and
had that moment of like oh my gosh
that's so cool and you know had all
these questions and it was just a little
bit of a geek out moment for myself and
for katherine
you know as we realized like okay you
know that that that was part of the goal
you know is to
is to give some the woman here women
heroes of this mythology
um they're due well now we're not
strangers
i'm arthur so i'm going to go ahead and
do this and i feel bad because i'm sure
you're going to get it a lot but let's
just
put it out there who's the better leader
arthur barack
i am i'm i'm gonna go with nimway
because we've seen
we've seen more of it but um
but it's one of those things where i
think uh he's not really he hasn't
earned the right to
to lead at this point and um he's still
discovering himself
but uh but definitely nimway you learned
a lot playing a politician that's a good
political answer
listen listen
but i mean it brings us to a point
though obviously you know this is
arthur's been played by a lot of people
from everyone from you know sean connery
to the guys from monty python so what
did you
particularly want to bring to this
character what what did you want to put
your stamp on it with
the material you were given and just how
you approached him yeah i
my whole thing was i never wanted to
play the legend the myth
i never wanted to play this idea that i
was trying to play into something
so i always wanted to to portray the
character as vulnerable
from the get-go because i think that's a
true leader we understand through their
vulnerabilities and their understanding
of
everyone and um he comes from a very
rough kind of black background
um in the beginning and and we're still
diving into that still as
in a story that it's it's about him
finding himself and i think
it's one of those things where that's
that's who i wanted to portray him as as
someone who's
is an everyday person um that people put
this myth
on him that every battle and every
journey he goes through that
the story keeps growing around him yeah
it's really interesting right because i
mean obviously you know when that name
is next to your role on the sheet you
know there's a lot that comes with it
and a lot of other things that you've
got to sort of i guess
be like committed to but from the
previous iterations
is there one besides cursed that you
particularly like like is there
either body python maybe sword of the
stone i don't know what you got
i i'll be honest with you i really liked
i really enjoyed watching merlin as a
kid
and bradley james is his version is is
really uh
it just felt like like for that story it
made complete sense and
i think the great thing is even monty
python all these things it's
i kind of take it back to like the whole
barack obama thing it's like everybody
has a different version when they play
him of that person
which you believe in you know jordan
peele's version
it's so it's some moments you're like oh
it's it's like a character to the
character but you're like but no that is
barack that is him
and so i think that was exciting the
exciting part about playing this role is
every actor you you i can't be bradley
james i've got to bring my own version
so
it was exciting to play that that role
no it's really good and you do a very
good job with it and it's funny that you
mentioned merlin because it's another
one of these like really
sweeping epic multi-episode tales and
i know coming into this that is like a
totally different
beast so how did you approach this
because y'all were on set for like 10
months right
shooting this really big story don't
want to even thinking about it again
it's um yeah it was it was it was such a
wild journey
especially from day one when we got
there and um erica the head of
hair and makeup would bring this board
in and you were like she's like this is
what the worlds look like
and i was like oh i didn't even know
that this is what we were going into
and in terms of i thought okay this is
gonna be a big journey but it just kept
getting bigger and bigger in scale and
i could see how excited the netflix team
were and everybody was about bringing
the story to life and
um it's one of those things where it
feels like you can only get bigger and
bigger if it goes
hopefully going forward so um it's
exciting it's exciting and it's
it's i loved merlin so it's it's one of
those things where uh
i have a soft spot for all kind of
versions of of the king arthur tale and
i think it's exciting version too yeah i
mean
catherine talked about how much she had
to go in to prepare for this i mean
again you guys are
going in that like game of thrones like
really
heavy levels of pre-production and scale
so
what did you have to do are you doing
the horseback riding the sword work like
how much did you have to
end it was so much it was every day was
you you had to look in the mirror and be
like i can do something else i can i can
get better at something else it's not
just learning your lines it's
um emotionally bringing fan the fantasy
world to life is actually so different
to
playing a rom-com or playing anything in
terms of the emotions have to be so
set set in in being a human being
because
you have to let the visual effects do
their thing so you just have to do your
job of connecting to the other person
and really believe it and and to believe
that someone has wings
it's like okay so but it's um yeah it
was
horseback riding um uh sword fighting
archery
uh boxing training trying to feel like
the an athlete in that time well not an
athlete but but it matter either warrior
or a soldier so it's um
it's it was so much training and then at
the same time learning alliance bringing
the emotion
but then once you learn all the
techniques of horseback riding and
everything you can just trust your
acting that you're going to be
in the world so it's it's it's it's a
lot of work
tell lord gray river i'm insulted by
this paltry show of folks
or better yet i'll send you back as
moans
our fans are huge viking fans so i'm
sure they're going gonna love to see you
in this i
i'm i'm very uh sure that they're gonna
enjoy your performance in this one as
well
but why do you think people are so
obsessed with the arthritis
why do you think they keep going back to
it i think
one of the things that is so appealing
about the story is
the question about the legitimacy and
eligibility of power
i love that elaborate who is
you know suited to wield this sword
which is the symbol for the ultimate
power
and what does this ultimate power do to
you
oh i think that is a really great take
on it and now i'm like want to go watch
all the other arthurian legends to see
which ones address it the best
i think obviously this one cursed
addresses
but what other well besides curse what
would be the other one
take that you particularly love like
whether it be monty python or sword in
the stone like
have you liked another those two
monty python holy grail you know growing
up
hilarious and loved sword in the stone
as a kid
so yeah they would probably be my
strongest impressions
from this and shout out shout out to
lady of the lake is in
uh monty python he's one of the few ones
that actually mentions her by name so
yeah he does mention that he got the
sword from lady of the lake in that one
which is like
what he's arguing with the french dudes
so obviously like i said our fans really
loved you and vikings and
are just obsessed with vikings in
general do you think maybe
you have an affinity for these fantasy
roles
or do they just come looking for you
like why do you think you you keep going
back to this epic
sort of like grand sleeping tales
well first like i think it's fun
uh i i'm a fan of the genre
um i grew up with fantasy i grew up
you know when all the kids played
football i took fencing lessons and
horseback riding because i wanted to be
robin hood
i grew up with like you know errol
flynn's robin hood and i wanted you know
that was like
that was the [ __ ] for me um so
so i think like in that sense like i i
come prepared for the genre
you know i i was into live role playing
and stuff as a
as a kid and so so i think i have
like you know a love for the genre uh
and then also like i have a you know a
strong theater background
i love the big expressions i love
having fun with my characters um
so so i think in that way i'm i'm suited
for it
yeah and i will say you look like you're
definitely having fun uh with merlin in
this one
i really love it is there anything
besides obviously it seems like you're
like a larper and horseback riding and
fencing was there anything specifically
on the set of vikings that you brought
into merlin whether it be
how you approach the character just like
knowing how to you know do these like
very like long stories um
well i think it was sort of like the
technicalities of it i've been on a big
show already
uh you know i'm used to sort of the
drill
and also like like i said all the
physical stuff like so many
like so many hours we we spent you know
stunt training
for the different fights in in on
vikings you know
so i didn't need a whole lot of fighting
training
for this one because i sort of came
prepared that's awesome
catherine talked about all the fight
training and how it was like a big deal
maybe you can tell me i have to ask will
floki be back on vikings like is it can
i ask like i know we don't say
exactly whether his character's alive
it's i mean it's looking kind of like if
he was i obviously couldn't you know
reveal that
but it's looking kind of bleak because
last time i saw he was like you know
caved in in a
cave volcano situation and then i
went on to do two tv shows since but
but hey here's to hoping this wretched
thing belongs at the bottom of a world
[Music]
what have you done obviously this is a
new version of the arthurian legend but
i'm just curious
why do you think folks keep wanting to
revisit the story
i think everybody loves a bit of magic
in all different forms shapes and sizes
that is one thing that people love to
see
it's something otherworldly and so i
think that's why
um the legends are so iconic really
do you have a favorite arthurian legend
like that you particularly enjoy
oh my god don't i have to say ours but
if i
don't say ours i'd say excalibur the
movie
is really good it's such an epic film
it's so fun i think helen mirren is
amazing in it as well
the cool thing about watching this show
is it's such like a big story like it's
just like a
really epic tale you know game of
thrones styling but i'm sure that
presents a lot of challenges trying to
tell that story
across 10 episodes really kind of
shooting like 10 little mini independent
films so
how did you guys approach making that
happen
wow yeah i completely agree like it's
it's such an epic
show um there is there's no small scenes
there are no small moments that it's
it's
everything is life and death and i think
the sets and the makeup and the costumes
everything is a reflection of that it's
it's kind of everyone it's like that go
hard or go home kind of attitude
and you know seeing people sit in the
makeup chair for sometimes four hours at
a time
um you know supporting artists coming in
and having
these incredible prosthetics put on and
transforming them completely um and
the sets are unbelievable i mean your
jaw was literally dropping every single
day on set you know there was
a whole medieval village that was made
in a forest
and that was one of those days where i
just thought this is unbelievable
it's you're right it is like 10 mini
movies they're like movie sets
so i was kind of blown away and really
taken aback it was just
one of the most amazing experiences i've
ever had um
in this profession and you know once you
add the
horses and all the there's so many um
there's so many hours and hours and
hours of work that go into this from so
many different people that are working
so hard to bring this to life and so i'm
really proud and excited to be a part of
it and
and for everyone to be able to show off
their work you know i can't wait
you know when we talked to folks like
katherine and daniel and devin they
definitely talked about
how much work they had to do for the
horse riding and sword fighting did you
have to do a ton of that kind of work
too to get ready
yeah absolutely i mean i i don't do any
um
sword fighting or fighting kind of
things in the show but i do
um ride a horse and i was absolutely
terrified i've not had any experience
riding
horses before um so it was definitely
something i was really nervous about
but the team that we worked with to
teach us how to ride horses were
incredible they were also the stunt team
and an amazing group of people that
really made us feel
so safe and calm on set and i mean it's
really difficult to be sat on top of
this
majestic animal trying to speak as well
as not
die as well as just like make sure you
don't annoy the horse
and just kind of like there are so many
different things at play that it's
really quite terrifying but it was it
was good fun and i really enjoyed it by
the end i'd like to think i'm
an okay horse rider now so again this is
the first time we're seeing nimway the
lady of the lake
told within the atherian legend
everything usually normally starts after
she gives
arthur excalibur um why do you think
it's important to tell her story
and why is it interesting for folks to
kind of see this part of the story
i think when i first read the synopsis
of the show
um you know in that sort of casting
breakdown that comes in
i saw it's rooted in the arthurian
legends and so i thought wow okay i
can't wait to read the script and when i
read it i was a bit like whoa this is so
different to anything i've ever really
seen before i don't really
it's so it's like it's been completely
mashed up and
blended around which is so um exciting
to see
and what's specifically amazing about it
being from the point of view of nimway
the lady of the lake is that
that character is a character that we've
never really seen fully fleshed out
and which is really exciting because
there's so much to tell from from this
woman and she's always kind of been this
sort of water nymph
really in in the legends that kind of
takes arthur to the isle of avalon at
the end of the tales after everything
said and done so it's really amazing
that we kind of
start with her
[Music]
this saw theory in legend like obviously
this is the first time we're really
seeing it from the lady of the lake
perspective but in general we've seen so
many adaptations like this
why do you think it's a story that we
just want to keep going back to
and telling in different ways yeah i you
know jack it's really interesting
because it's
it's a story that has kind of
generationally just kind of been told
over and over and over again there's
something that people
obviously really respond to in this and
maybe it's this kind of these characters
of these love triangles these sense of
kind of
right and wrong the knights of the round
table this idea that people like
know what's going on you know and and
are fighting for
justice or you know fighting for these
things and um
that there's some kind of sense that
people across all ages and
across all generations seem to kind of
respond to this story and
uh i i i was you know having
read versions of it i um
i am kind of quite interested i think
it's just very interesting
character storytelling at the end of the
day they're kind of intriguing
um mythical characters that obviously
represent something in all of us that we
kind of
kind of relate to somewhere
yeah it's been like a common theme when
folks are talking about it is just this
idea of like being special and plucked
from obscurity and they all kind of have
that
uh do you have a favorite take on it
maybe soar in the stone maybe monty
python
yeah well you know my my you know i'm a
brit so monty python was my
my understanding of of this of this uh
you know it's only a flesh wound kind of
thing
um i remember watching excalibur
as a kid and just thinking this is the
weirdest
most bizarre most kind of intriguing
um version of this story you know it
seemed like a kind of
um but but i think you're right like
there's something about
being chosen and and a sword only coming
out if it's you
you know there's this sense that like we
all want to believe that there
there is something that only we can do
um
so i think in this story people kind of
tell it a lot of different ways but
uh i you know munzee python is
definitely up there for me
of the version of this story that i i
had first seen
yeah and it shouts out the lady of the
lake in that one which is it
um also obviously all of you but
especially the weekly y'all had a lot of
like horse fighting
uh sword fighting talk about getting
physically prepared for this one because
i know talking to katherine she said it
was a lot
yeah you know i don't know if catherine
told you but we kind of all
ended up on this farm in the middle of
england
um learning to kind of fight and
and do horse riding and stunts and i i i
can't think of a better way to get
actors to kind of
get better at a thing than to put other
actors
doing the same thing and getting better
at it in front of your very eyes so that
you kind of have this competitive
edge of kind of oh okay right devon's uh
he's benching that and he's doing those
okay right i gotta go and do it
you know so that that was part of it and
then for me you know part of it was
doing a lot of works
kind of on my own in in terms of
movement and
um doing things that i felt that would
inform the character
especially in his his ability to move so
taking ballet classes and um
i took a foraging class uh
and went up to scotland to take this
foraging class where i learned to like
live
on you know berries and nuts and things
like that just things that i felt like
would be a way of telling his story
because he doesn't say a lot
but that his movement and and the way he
interacts with nature would be an
important part of
of of this arc so those were the things
that i kind of wanted to focus on as
well
i'm nim wei this is pim
why do you think this is a story that we
keep wanting to revisit
in either television and film and really
any kind of medium but
even from different perspectives like
this one
i think because there's there's always
another perspective you can tell it from
i think with any story there as long as
there are
you know multiple characters within it
there are
infinite perspectives you can tell it
from and
uh as far as i'm aware there hasn't
really been a perspective from lady of
the lake
in terms of screen adaptions i may be
completely wrong though and i haven't
done proper research
but on television i think you are
correct there's been a few like
like animation i think there was like a
couple of ones i did the research for
you don't work
[Laughter]
by the way you're sure it's really nice
oh thank you i dressed up for y'all
because you all are so fancy on the show
with all that like
high level production value which is
actually my next question because it is
such
a big production like the costumes and
the horse works so what was it like
sort of tackling this really long form
because you guys were there for like 10
months right
yeah it was a long long shoot
and the costumes uh i the coursing
department is always my
favorite department no offense to all
the other departments
but that's where i'm happiest and that's
where i feel
uh as though i grow um mostly into my
character through the costume especially
when it's
um a completely different time you know
such as this one you know saxon medieval
times and
um although i did feel
with uh some of my costumes they did
almost feel
60s and 70s but yeah i mean you don't
you don't get clothes like that
these days so that was particularly
exciting to indulge in
um in that department no i loved the
scale of it i love the costumes
um also i should have asked you this one
what's your favorite like
of the previous iterations everything
there's like monty python
and you know sword and the stone do you
have a favorite take
besides cursed on the arthurian legend
like prior to this one
um there's i i want to say it's 80s
the that you know the cartoon i'm pretty
sure it was made in the 80s
but i could in the stone yeah that
absolutely i love i love that cartoon
yeah
merlin and what was her name the witch
in that one like the mad
like like the mad woman in that one i
loved her
um so i will ask you this one because i
asked this one to katherine and she had
her own take so
maybe you you'll you'll back her or not
but geralt obrivia is like
the king of uh netflix like fantasy
and now i would say nimway is like the
queen so
going head-to-head who do you think
takes it in a fight
that is a toughie i actually finally
enough watched the first episode of the
witcher yesterday i hadn't seen any of
it yet
and there is some incredible sword
fighting in that
but catherine sure knows how to wield a
sword as well
it would be a tight one but i'm gonna
i'm gonna be biased and i'm gonna say
catherine
i think that's a good that's an
absolutely that's an absolutely good
choice
um you didn't have to do as much as she
did obviously with a lot of the like
stunt and whatever but
what did you have to do to sort of like
pre-production like get ready for
for prim and like sort of bring her to
life did you have to learn anything
specifically different for
um i i didn't have to do
um yeah i didn't have to do any sword
training
um i did some horse riding
um training because i had to ride
[Music]
come on man uh bareback because
catherine
and i we share a horse uh briefly and
she sits on the saddle and i sit behind
the saddle so i had to get used to
sitting riding a horse bareback um
because i had to sit on its like hip
bones pretty much
which was pretty uncomfortable but i got
used to it um
so that yeah in terms of training that's
as far as
i went um and then the rest of pym is
just
up to having a really positive mindset
and going with the flow
this is our only chance of survival
[Applause]
you